un carguero lleno de trigo cruza el
bósforo una transacción posible gracias
al acuerdo firmado por rusos y
ucranianos el pasado mes de julio este
compromiso conocido como la iniciativa
del mar Negro ha permitido exportar
desde Ucrania más de 24 millones de
toneladas de cereales
exportaciones vitales para aliviar la
crisis alimentaria mundial
es extremadamente importante que la
iniciativa del mar Negro siga
funcionando no solo para continuar el
comercio eficiente del grano a través
del mar Negro hoy sino también para la
próxima cosecha y la próxima temporada
Necesitamos poder seguir teniendo el
flujo de grano necesario para
estabilizar el mercado
Moscú propuso prorrogar el acuerdo dos
meses más el texto original firmado bajo
los auspicios de Turquía permitía una
prórroga de 120 días sin embargo desde
las partes mediadoras no se ha
especificado la duración de la
ampliación del acuerdo Aunque Ucrania
sostiene que es por cuatro meses Rusia
por dos
negociación Rusia negocia para obtener
facilidades para sus propias
exportaciones
Por otra parte Rusia no quiere que se
considere que bloquea las exportaciones
de los países al sur que necesitan esos
cereales
una segunda parte de la iniciativa se
refería a las exportaciones de
fertilizantes antes de la guerra y las
sanciones
Moscú enviaba fertilizantes a todo el
mundo hoy más de 260.000 toneladas de
fertilizantes rusos están bloqueadas en
los puertos europeos al kremlin le
gustaría poder reanudar este comercio
con normalidad a pesar de las sanciones
económicas las autoridades ucranianas
agradecieron el sábado a las Naciones
Unidas y a Turquía la prórroga del
acuerdo de granos